this is blogger nikita dimentov he lives
in the eastern city of kharkiv and he's
explaining to his followers how their
donations are being spent to help
civilians on the front line
across ukraine along shifting front
lines from the north to the east and to
the south civilians are under attack
when they emerge from basements and
shelters as here in the town of irpin
close to kiev
it is often to a landscape they can
neither recognize nor comprehend
homes destroyed hospitals overwhelmed
heating water and electricity cut off
and with limited avenues of escape
that's why safe passage is so important
now humanitarian corridors out of
volnovaca and the port city of mariopol
in the south failed on saturday because
of continued russian attacks
negotiations are said to be ongoing
resistance has done much to slow
russia's ground advance
so heavier firepower is being unleashed
from the air
yet the ukrainian government's urgent
calls for a no-fly zone have gone
unanswered
which explains this angry warning by
president vladimir zelinsky to the nato
alliance
all the people who die from this day
forward will also die because of you
because of your weakness and because of
your lack of unity
nato is not willing to shoot down
russian aircraft and risk being drawn
into a wider war with russia so ukraine
must act alone for as long as its air
defenses last
this is cockpit video from a russian
helicopter gunship
and this is the sort of response
ukraine's army is able to deliver one
helicopter gunship down
[Music]
and in the north a russian warplane is
downed
its wreckage smoldering among suburban
homes
for those who do make it out of besieged
and bombarded parts of the country it is
to ul vive that many come for now a
place of safety behind the lines
irina and her boys have fled kharkiv
leaving husband ruslan behind to fight
it is a feature of war that some are
inspired to act with great courage
in this case a seven-year-old dima
comforting his mom
[Music]
the children are terrified and they
don't know why they need to leave their
home
i don't understand why i need to run
away and leave my husband behind
we left him alone to protect our city
moscow says it is not attacking civilian
targets the claims to the contrary are
fake news that the destruction in city
centers and residential areas across the
country is the work instead of ukrainian
forces and saboteurs
try telling that to the people here
try saying it to the people under
occupation in the south of the country
in places like herson and berdyansk and
on the root of russia's advance in
zaporizia all three places saw large
protests on saturday against the
presence of russian troops
and try telling irina and her children
that russian forces are liberating
ukraine as they claim from nazis and
nationalists
as they make their way into a bomb
shelter even here
where they had hoped to escape the war
jonah al jazeera ulviv